all right guys how are you I am here
with Jim O'Shaughnessy an absolute
legend on on wall street he's laughing
as I say that which means that is
probably true Jim thank you so much for
for joining us well I can tell you that
my wife and children say I am a legend
in my own mind that's half the battle
actually no I'm super excited to have
you I think you know a lot of times we
spend time talking with people who are
in the decentralization I'm kind of
cryptocurrency industry and mindset you
have a very different background coming
from a long career on Wall Street and
traditional finance and so I'm excited
to hear what you kind of think about all
of this the hoopla and hype around
around crypto sure not glad to be here
so for those that don't know you why
don't we go through your background
first and then you can make it sound as
legendary as you'd like well actually I
came up as a young guy just I fell in
love with the stock market at an early
age that's kind of weird but I grew up
in st. Paul Minnesota and we had a
Family Foundation and they would once a
quarter have meetings for the foundation
in st. Paul and when I got to be old
enough they invited me to the dinners a
bunch of Irish people you can imagine
how those dinners would go but I was
listening to my uncle and father argue
about the merits of IBM mhm and they
were talking all about whoever the
current CEO was then everything that
they were describing was people and I'm
like listening to this thinking I think
that that's an awful way to buy a public
company maybe if you're doing a start-up
the people matter a lot more but if
you're buying one of the biggest
companies in the world
I think numbers are morn so I went down
to the James J Hill library which was a
great reference library in st. Paul all
the railroad barons set up these
enormous libraries and so they were they
had everything originally I grabbed the
sp
tearsheet book which has 500 companies
in it and being potentially one of the
laziest people on the planet decided
that that was not going to work out for
me so I thought why don't I just look at
the 30 stocks in the Dow
um and so I found a book the hair that
went all the way back to 1885 and it
showed every single component of the Dow
from 1885 forward and learned a lot of
really interesting things for example
they kicked IBM out of the Dow before it
went up something like 30 fold and they
replaced it with AT&T which went up one
times so you know had they left you know
certain stocks in the Dow the Dow would
be vastly higher today anyway what I did
was I lists the 30 for each year and
then I just did the standard numbers
price price to earnings dividend yield
price to book all of those things and
literally this is 1978 I had to do this
by hand on a big paper spreadsheet and
so I I got an inkling that not paying up
for a stock was a good way to invest I
did a comparison between the Dow stocks
with the highest peas verse the lowest
peas and there was no comparison
buying annually the 10 with the lowest
p/e just absolutely obliterated the ten
highest p/e stocks but then I also
looked at dividend yield I ultimately
wrote an article for Barron's in 1993
you might be familiar with the famous
dogs of the Dow strategy well I took
that back to when the modern Dow was
created there were a couple of their
books so I do not claim credit for
having invented that strategy but the
other books only really went to the
1950s mmm-hmm and so I thought well you
know the Dow has been around since the
late 20s let's go see how it does and
we'll have this huge out-of-sample hold
out period to see whether it works then
as well it did and of course I'm an 18
year old male I had other interests
including girls and parties and all
those things so I kind of set that as
side went to college and then met my
current wife of 36 years at a college
summer party graduated college and then
started back in earnest and now I had
computers so now I was really dating and
so I got hired by a big pension fund in
the Twin Cities called control data it
was an old conglomerate and back then
you know the dark ages really were dark
a lot of people didn't even know what
style their portfolio manager was using
were they growth were they value where
they growth at a reasonable price
you know all of these things and they
said we want you to come in and make
some sense of this for us so I founded
the company of Shaughnessy Capital
Management in 1987 to do that and we
created what were called normal
portfolios they're like highly
specialized benchmarks it's not like
using the S&P 500 or using the Russell 1
value you know as a kind of a general
benchmark for how manager might be doing
what we did was take the manager's
portfolios put them on a database look
at the most extreme differences in their
portfolio from that universe and then
use the most extreme differences to
screen the same universe for a portfolio
of stocks that looked acted and most
importantly performed like the
underlying manager the whole purpose of
a normal portfolio was really simple it
was is this manager through his or her
activity trading selling buying adding
any significant value to their
underlying stat style or is it all the
style mm-hmm well what we found was my
kind of aha moment even though we
attributed huge transaction costs to the
portfolio's that we created as the
normals they killed their underlying
managers and I don't mean just by a
percent or two they absolutely destroyed
them why because this
was the inkling of I wonder if that
cartoon by Kelly is right Pogo we've met
the enemy and it's us and that's when I
started to develop the theory that
basically human beings are designed to
suck as investors right so we are
optimized towards a history that no
longer exists and hasn't existed in eons
right when we're out walking on the
savanna and we see a bush rustling it's
a probably a very good idea to turn
around and run like hell right because
you don't know what that is it could be
a predator it could be something else
but you're not gonna take your chances
you're just gonna run well all of our
ancestors of everyone sitting in this
room ran so the ones who didn't run the
braver all got killed and so that that
made us optimized to be very very
fearful of perceived threats and so when
markets as we know are incredibly
volatile what do people do the amygdala
takes over the fear takes over the brain
and there's almost nothing you can do to
fight it unless you are a quantitative
investor who does not override their
model right
so I started reading a lot of what is
now known as behavioral finance and
actually I found a book by a guy by the
name of Robin Dawes Britt who his book
was actually about psychotherapy but he
had a great chapter about all of the
studies that had been done over
actuarial outcomes ie algorithmic
outcomes and clinical outcomes that
means I'm the doctor diagnosing you and
when they started all these things in
the 50s they all thought all the
researchers thought that the human
expert was going to soar above these
simple algorithmic solutions the
algorithmic solutions destroyed them and
they destroyed them for one reason and
one reason only they were consistently
applied
and time and time again we humans are
far more interesting right we get
hungover we have a fight with our spouse
we're in a bad mood or we're in a good
mood and we let that influence our
decisions in financial markets you know
there's a study that just sticks out in
my mind and that is about people trying
to get parole if you want to get promote
her ol make sure that you are one of the
first appointments of the day the people
who are at the you know the eight to ten
in their hearing they get parole at at
something like eighty five percent of
the time
guess who almost never gets paroled the
people whose appointment is right before
lunch and why is that the judges are
hungry and so they're like nope nope
nope time for lunch and you know it's
amazing but I've collected these
examples over the years and you know I
often say to people we have known about
this for a long long time one of the
best books that I think every new
investor should read is reminiscence of
a stock operator the fictionalized life
of Jesse Livermore who was a big trader
back in the 20s and literally was short
the market going into the 1929 crash
people he had higher security guards
because people wanted to tear him limb
from limb because again if you
understand human history if you
understand human psychology we all look
for a scapegoat right we had very famous
scapegoats during the financial crisis
right and that hasn't changed at all and
so he had to go into hiding and
ultimately the real sadness of Livermore
is he ended up killing himself in the
sherry Lehmann hotel here in New York
because he finally had that last trade
which bankrupted him and even though he
knew right and his whole book
reminiscence of a stock operator is all
about nothing ever changes the same
thing that led Isaac Newton to buy in at
the top of the South Sea trading company
back in the 1700s is happening to us
today
so I always say different play or sorry
different players same play yep
absolutely
so speaking of bubbles buying the top
and in kind of nothing changing you know
you have a historian type view of
financial markets over a very long
period centuries of time and I tend to
agree with you that different players
same game if you apply that to
cryptocurrency Bitcoin digital assets I
think that many people would argue we're
actually seeing different players same
game on steroids no question about that
and so you know my disclaimer is what I
know about crypto Patrick o Shaughnessy
my son taught me and and literally he
taught me in a Wichita hotel lobby while
we were waiting for the golf bus to come
and I looked out of my way all right
Patrick you know cuz he's doing his
whole hash power yep thing and which I
thought turned out really well but I go
okay I'm five years old explained it to
me and so I have I let's put it this way
I have just enough knowledge to be
dangerous and so and so I always go into
my standard here's something financial
people never say enough I don't know
okay I don't know and if we're gonna use
that as our jumping-off point I'm happy
to talk about it but listeners I don't
know I don't know sometimes the three
yeah it gets it across absolutely I mean
look I think that the beauty and why I
want to talk to you right was there is
some ignorant sin bliss or are there
some bliss and ignorance right around
the asset almost doesn't matter no right
and and look I I've always said that the
four horsemen of the investment
apocalypse are fear greed hope and
ignorance and if you think about that
only ignorance is not an emotion fear
greed and hope have wiped out more
fortunes than anything historically in
auction-based markets and you know
look the last edge in my opinion is to
arbitrage human behavior why markets
change minute by minute human being and
human nature changes imperceptibly
millennium by millennium
there's your edge mm-hmm right because
even though people are gonna say oh
we'll never do that we would never ever
ever do that they say that right up
until the minute they do it so you were
kind of looking for you know where have
we seen this movie what what and I think
just just to clarify right so the asset
is highly liquid global you know it's
all the stuff but the bubble right or
the correction that we just saw over
let's say the last 12 months I think is
a pattern especially we literally look
at it on a chart that is very very
reminiscent in almost an exact overlay
of many markets previously oh definitely
in the fourth edition of what works on
Wall Street we had two charts in there
one was the South Sea Bubble that Isaac
Newton lost a fortune in and the other
one was the Nasdaq and they're identical
basically really and you know we the the
the time that I remember that is so
reminiscent of what we're seeing now a
little a little of the edges off though
because the corrections been pretty
significant generally speaking when the
corrections get to be this significant
people are feeling real pain and so the
ambulance and the enthusiasm definitely
wanes like rothschild
he's saying wait until there's blood in
the streets to buy but going in to the
dot-com boom so this I wrote a paper
called the internet contrary on which I
can send you if you're interested in
April of 1999 basically outlining why I
was about as bearish about any trend
during my career and I said when this
ends and it's gonna end badly the number
of books that get written about the by
the by authors it's just going to end
so badly because ultimately economics
matters mm-hmm and and then what did I
do
I founded an Internet company not too
smart this way uh so it was a company
called net folio it was the first
robo-advisor in 2000 and the the
valuation extremes were I mean it was
crazy it was literally crazy and what
what happens here's the guy who's
talking about you've got to have rules
governing your emotions you cannot get
excited about this it's gonna ruin you
it's gonna ruin you mm-hmm getting a
good idea which I think it was a good
idea for a robo-advisor you could it's
not like the current robos it actually
lets you trade without a cost and you
could build your portfolio we would show
you a bunch of back tests on portfolios
and you could go from very conservative
very aggressive anti-smoking Kick Philip
Morris out the next name on the list
comes up so it was a pretty slick
environment and offering and of course
the ultimate internet crash came when a
guy by the name of Jack Willoughby who I
I know he's he's a very interesting guy
who writes for Barron's
and very smart but sometimes a little
like Colombo in other words he's so
smart he tries to kind of convince you
that he's not but you can see it it's
those are the ones to watch out for
definitely and so he kind of thought he
was musing with this editor and he goes
I wonder how much cash all of these
internet companies have yeah and what
they're burn rate is yeah well it would
seem to me that if they can't raise more
money that these are all their death
dates yep and they're like do it write
the story now the story's name you can
find it online I'll send you a bunch of
these links but they changed the name
from burn rate to something else burning
money or whatever but that story
literally took the internet down because
it was like everyone collectively woke
up at exactly the same time
and went oh my god we're all gonna die
yep and boom and and that was kind of it
it was the end all the VCS we had VCS
wanted to throw huge valuations at us
disappeared mm-hmm and and you know the
the number of careers that got ruined in
that I once debated a guy on stage
because we always come at investing kind
of from a value perspective yep although
we do use momentum and other things so
we're not you know and in quality and we
have a very kind of complicated sauce
now but he was on stage in Minneapolis
with me big crowd and his and it was a
debate and his advice to the people in
the audience was only by technology
companies and especially Internet
companies that was it and I kind of
looked at him I said I am sure I heard
you wrong you didn't just say to by not
only just one sector but a specific
component of that sector and he goes he
goes the the the economy has radically
changed forever it is never going back
to bricks and mortar and you know I was
39 at the time he's saying Jim you know
you're you're a bit of an old codger for
someone who's only 39 years old and I
said but but math and things didn't go
well it's we like to say the pesky facts
facts and you know so-so markets have
always done this and I think that that
is the thing my big areas of study
obviously are in the on the quantitative
side of things I I've spent 30 years
studying that side of the market but
I've also spent a lot of time
understanding evolutionary biology and
psychology because if you get a really
good understanding of men and women and
the way we are emotionally designed you
can you can have much greater faith in
saying nope it's gonna happen exactly
the same way it happened before mm-hmm
and and you know it's funny because
something that didn't cause anyone any
consternation six months ago now becomes
that is that's gonna kill us so you know
the US government is gonna make crypto
illegal okay and they're gonna get the
death penalty if you are found having
crypto pretty strong deterrent mm-hmm
you know FDR did it with gold he
confiscated all gold in the 1930s
because he was going moving completely
off the gold standard because he had to
and everyone complied and so having the
world's biggest economy be unable to
participate in crypto would definitely
put a crimp in its style conversely if
you look at black markets right and that
is something that I've looked at over
the years black markets are enormous
even in free market societies like our
own mm-hmm think about housekeepers
think about drugs think about people who
sell cigarettes that don't pay the tax
yeah so even in a relatively free market
like the US huge black market and then
take places like Venezuela or whatever
and it's all black market the
interesting thing about those black
markets is they are all priced in u.s.
dollars so there is an inertia a huge
amount of money that's at stake and sure
could some of those people cook convert
their their dollars to cryptocurrency
actually there's a lot of good reasons
why they should right but you know a lot
of again inertia is another one of the
laws that I just love and thank you
Sir Isaac Newton you know people are
really strange in that I've got time
time I've got time and then their time
runs out mm-hmm
so I think that you know I I say I don't
know enough to to be a bull or a bear on
the whole space you we were talking
earlier and and I think that one of your
strategies I know you have many but one
of your strategies about who during the
gold rush you know building the hotels
Eldin the pickaxes selling the pails
that works mm-hmm that works really well
and so I think that there's all sorts of
secondary and ancillary people who can
make a lot of money from crypto but I
definitely think that the the the crypto
world is still mysterious enough even to
somebody like me who knows just enough
to be dangerous I know guys I'm 58 so I
know guys my own age don't have a clue
yep and they'll call me on the phone and
they'll say Jim you know you you
understand this crypto thing I have no
here's Patrick's number call him because
and and frankly we O'Shaughnessy family
partners which is our family office did
make a small investment in crypto just
to see how it worked
because we thought well this has the
potential to be big so we want to see
I'm a huge believer in you can't learn
anything unless you've got to get in the
game
yep you know because what happens is you
intellectualize everything and oh I
would have definitely sold there no you
wouldn't you wouldn't have sold there
everyone's a genius and I'd say exactly
exactly everyone's from Lake woebegone
right above average so I I believe that
you know we're doing a lot of really
interesting work right now on machine
learning and
again to really really understand you've
got to have you've got to have your own
money online absolutely
what let's talk about kind of the
international you know kind of economic
situations that are occurring right so
you've got obviously Turkey right you've
got Iran you've got that it's way below
Zimbabwe never these comfort countries
are either close to or are experiencing
hyperinflation etc you know is there any
time previously that you can think of
where you know there was I don't wanna
say it's widespread because it's still
you know just a handful of countries and
they're kind of the usual suspects type
thing but where economic situations are
chaos to some degree internationally
really drove a change in investor
interest in certain asset classes in the
u.s. not so much in the US but the best
example of hyperinflation ruining a
country was the by Mar Republic in
Germany which extended to kind of vassal
states Austria for a brief time people
were literally going to the zoo and
killing the animals to eat them Wow
so things have gotten a lot worse but
generally speaking when you have when
you have several things in place you
your your risk of that kind of nightmare
economic apocalypse is reduced rather
dramatically the first things is a
relatively free market the United States
likes to say we're a free market we're
not a free market Society we are a
regulated in many instances capture by
corporations of the political system but
still relatively free definitely
compared to counterparts exactly right
so we you know we're the cleanest shirt
in the pile of dirty laundry the other
thing that's really really important is
the rule of law I think actually the
rule of law is the most important
when you can adjudicate your disputes
through a well-set-up and well respected
and believed in system that goes a
really really long way towards keeping
all those boogeymen of hyperinflation
and everything out of the picture so
it's not a surprise that when you see
those kinds of economic events and
they're devastating and I I don't want
to sound at all flip these people are
really really suffering and and so but
you know there's a script for not having
that there's kind of a script for having
it to come and the script for not having
it is not democratic not free
institutions no rule of law and whenever
you see a country that adheres to those
those what I would call that toxic brew
the chances of that kind of thing
happening are much much higher but keep
in mind there's nobody in Venezuela
buying anything other than in u.s.
dollars mm-hmm and that has remained
very very stable there so if you're
crazy and want to you know use their
currency well good luck
get your wheelbarrows out yep but again
markets are fascinating things because
what they do is they find a way and and
it's like so just a brief digression I
tend to have a political outlook that is
very different than most people I am
what I would say kind of a libertarian
and and I think of things like drug laws
I think drug laws are insane we have all
of the history that shows that they are
insane
we have all of the history that shows
they created a much larger mafia and we
have all of the history of showing even
in a great free democracy country like
our own a corruption at the upper levels
of government which is very troubling
look at what they've done in Portugal
they made drugs
they decriminalize drugs 15 years ago
guess what's happened drug use has
plunged all of the good things and all
the kind of you know things that you
could if you were able to really think
about it happen now does that mean that
I personally take drugs no I don't you
know I I really don't what's at a party
right coming home and look at my wife
and saying you have no idea what a Boy
Scout you're married to but but I I
think that this is really interesting
right because it is you know I think
most people want to do what they're told
they're not allowed to do oh right it's
a little bit there's an element of that
and so this this work that you've done
on the human psychology and how they
interact with economic market stuff is
really interesting because I think also
you know somebody recently told me they
said I think there's a saying that you
know basically when people can print
money they will oh yeah right so and so
I think that you know when you look at
these you know kind of hyperinflation
countries literally there's no checks
and balances and so there's usually one
person who's kind of in charge of
everything and they print money yes they
do and you know what else is interesting
is I know and I can't disclose because I
you know it's kind of like I could tell
you but I'd have to kill you when we
changed our currency completely there
was a reason for that
mmm-hmm some very bad people had
Treasury plates and so in a advanced
democracy like the United States done I
mean that happened over night mm-hm
making those old plates absolutely
worthless so when you have a very high
functioning democracy with institutions
that have been around for a long long
time those types of things don't
generally happen and the other thing
that I always tell people and I usually
get non Wall Street people just laughing
in my face and it is people do not
really understand
that Wall Street is entirely based on
trust you know get decayed you know what
decay means don't know right if you get
decayed in a trade you're probably never
ever gonna trade with that guy or woman
again ever and they are effectively
boxed out because everything that we do
is done on our word you know when you
get on the phone you say whatever like
the guy buying the crypto yeah it wasn't
on the phone but if if his counterparty
couldn't trust him well the markets
would collapse so I think that the
United States obviously has probably one
of the best functioning market systems
some in Europe especially interestingly
enough Eastern the former Eastern
European states like Estonia etc they
have set up some really cool stuff and
you know like flat tax rates you can do
it all like computer because they had
the opportunity to mmm right and and
that's the other thing that I'm a big
believer in legacy can be a problem
right so if you are a monster company
and all of your software is circa 1985
getting rid of that and updating it to
2018 is her clean effort and so you you
definitely you know I think you and your
team are in a position that's
interesting because you don't have to
deal with any of those situations and
you can you can kind of have best of
class right away absolutely let's talk a
little bit about money and kind of money
supply and so you know the US currency
is based on a inflationary model Bitcoin
is obviously based on a deflationary
model just given kind of again your
experience and markets and and you know
really taking this economic perspective
pros/cons
you know what do you think is kind of
your outlook on that deflationary model
and if it could work so
generally speaking we did a study of
when stocks performed the best okay and
interestingly enough they they did best
under moderate inflation interesting I'm
not high inflation but but very very
moderate inflation deflation is a scary
thing for an economy and if you think
about it for just a second you'll
understand why we are going out and and
let's say we both want to buy a car and
we need the car we need it for our job
we have we've got to get to our job etc
but we look at each other and we say
yeah but if we wait a month this is
gonna be like five hundred dollars
cheaper and so what happens in a
deflationary spiral is you lose the
confidence of the consumers and because
they think in their mind that wow if I
just wait it's gonna be a lot cheaper so
consumption declines precipitously and
people hang on to cash and so the the
you know the best-case scenario I think
would be if if the various crypto
currencies didn't have any you know that
they could truly be a store of value
mmm-hmm right with with very small
movements absolutely and that's really
because what if you have a different
deflationary model at some point sake
Bitcoin for a second 21 million bitcoins
will be mined and be available right
some will be lost some will you know
people won't remember they have them so
there's some you know kind of
circulation that is actually not
accessible but for the most part there
will be a set number and at that point
the logic I think holds that you know
there will be some market equal
equilibrium that's found right there
won't be kind of constant supply going
in or out of the system and so that
should be a decent store of value if you
can find that equilibrium and and that
stability in the price yes theoretically
big F yep
and so you
as an outsider who just is kind of
interested in this and and watching
where it's going mhm
I I definitely think a lot of those
thoughts you know III think well if you
really can't have something that people
look at as a store of value that has 20
and 30 percent movements because it's it
yet again to psychology yep if if if
we're getting all excited because our
Bitcoin went up 30% or we're despondent
because it went down 30% the fact is
that does not lead to a sense of
certainty about it and you know I think
that's something that the US dollar
still has it you know I've read all the
stuff on how it's a fiat currency and
you know yada-yada-yada debt crisis yeah
and and I'm not convinced I'm just not
convinced and when we did the QE it had
no inflationary effect and it had no
inflationary effect because there was
simply no demand for that money it got
put on people's bank balances and you
know when when people understand that
they don't go crazy right and so I think
I'm fascinated by the idea of a currency
that can keep its store of value I think
the proof work concept works really well
you know I think that the the whole
delivery system and the ability of
transport ability and all of that look I
think if you were designing a currency
there's a lot of really good features
yep of cryptocurrency and tell write
markets treat it like a speculative
asset as they have been and then
suddenly everyone's just like oh I I'm
not gonna do this it's almost as if even
if it is the best currency but you lose
the
the consumer confidence right of not
only price volatility right but security
right would be another piece and then
the part that I think gets lost in this
conversation a lot is the acceptance
right right so so even if I can store
value I either have to believe that
somebody else will one day want to buy
this from me
right so basically get out of that store
of value so another consumer etc but
then if it's money an actual currency I
have to be able to give it to somebody
in exchange for some other value see and
that is the magic of currency systems
and you know if you know your monetary
history you know that we've used things
all over the map as currency
you know clamshells literally yep
tulips obviously gold and and it has to
meet the criteria you have just outlined
you have to be absolutely certain that
if you want to buy my iPhone from me
that I will sell it to you and I will
accept that currency yes a store of
value for myself and you conversely have
to have exactly the same belief yep and
so that's where I find this is kind of
interesting right because I think that
if if the crypto market had been able to
kind of be introduced with a little less
volatility because the one thing that I
do know from the stock market volatility
terrifies and and I don't mean oh I'm
kind of nervous here I mean people do
incredibly rash and silly things we had
clients in the financial crisis taking
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
out of their bank account and putting it
in safety deposit boxes and and you know
I would be on the phone with them saying
that isn't gonna help you and and so you
know when people are and we're by the
way we are all the same everyone sitting
in this room everyone in your family and
my family everyone we've ever known we
are human beings Homo sapiens sapiens
right that's because the new priek
frontal cortex but we are still being
you know and I can't remember the author
and I would love to give credit to him
because it's such a great quote but he
says something along the lines of you
know we are operating 21st century
software on 50 thousand year old
hardware and you know I mean I think
that just encapsulated we we just are
not optimized and so my my thing was to
say you know what I'm just gonna admit I
don't know you know I don't know what I
do know that if I was left to my own
devices I would panic - mmhmm right
mm-hm because I'm a human being and I'm
not having been excluded excluded or
excused from that class and you know I
always shake my heads at the people who
I did a little experiment on Twitter
last week and I said I put a picture of
the Wall Street Journal from after the
big crash in 1987 and I said you're
reading this for the first time what do
you do
well of course like more than a hundred
buy back up the truck no you wouldn't
but that's what's so cool about the way
the human mind works they honestly
believe that they would have mm-hmm
because and they don't understand that
they have hindsight and that that
happened 30 years ago and so it's in the
past and there's no emotion right mm-hmm
and so you really if you tried to get
into an argument with them you couldn't
convince them that they thought that
they were lying
yep that's the funny way the mind works
so I I definitely think that we are all
subject to these rules
and if you want to understand any
financial instrument understand this
human behavior and interaction and then
see where are you in that phase right
how do you see behavior change between
what I think many would consider the
great investors from everyone else is
there a change or is it they've
basically done the prep work to prevent
themselves from making mistakes during
those those weak moments so well Sir
John Templeton was famous for when
stocks were doing very poorly he would
make a list of his favorite stocks and
put buy orders in at prices way below
where they were and his reasoning was if
the stocks ever got to that level he
would not have the guts to put the order
in
he just couldn't do it so there was a
guy who understood his own human nature
I love that what we do is we are
entirely rules based I never override I
mean you know people would say to me
well you know is it the formulas is it
no it's not the formulas you know if
you've got the best idea in the world
you can scream it from the rooftops and
people either won't believe you well you
know hear you and certainly even if they
attempt to do it won't do it right yep
and so we're not worried about that what
we worry about is look we're we're
constantly improving our algorithms that
select models and portfolios and I've
got a great research team that's what we
spend all of our time on but the thing
that I think I am proudest of is the
fact that in my 30 plus year career
history as an investor I have never
emotionally given in mmm-hmm by
overwriting a model by overriding a
model yep and we had and that's hard you
know and just just to clarify so people
who are honest ages us what you're
talking about there is you have a model
that is just you know based on data
right and formulas that you've created
that tell you when to buy when to sell
when to hold right basically precisely
they give you direct
they give us directions and you can
either listen or not yeah right we we
used to we used to have a context or a
contest back at O'Shaughnessy capital
where we would put the list of 50 names
that were being selected by our small
cap growth strategy and we would have
everyone guess which we're gonna be the
ten big performers in which we're gonna
be the ten worst performers well you can
see this coming a mile away everyone
that they thought were gonna be the 10
worst ended up being for the most part
the 10 best and the 10 best ended up
being the 10 worst and so I just you
know I basically made my mind up after a
trade that I actually wrote about when I
sold a huge position of putt puts right
literally on the Friday before the
Monday stock market crash Tahoe and I
did that which I'll send you a link to I
did that because I was watching TV and I
was listening to the radio and everyone
was like oh this is so overdone we're
gonna have the biggest bounce panic
rally ever and I let my emotions
determine what I was doing and I was
sold all the puts and then Monday
happened and so I thought of it I used
to keep it you had for a bad Monday but
for other reasons
yes but but I I also recommend people
keep journals so that you remember what
you actually were thinking in real time
because again the brain will play
beautiful tricks on you it will make you
think that you were not thinking that
way at all then you go back and there it
is in your own handwriting staring at
you in the face
and you go oh god I was thinking that
and so but I I wrote a lot about that
thought about a lot that and this was
concurrent with reading all these books
on on the efficacy of these various
decision trees and by the way not just
Wall Street horse handicappers
handicapping races doctors diagnosing
liver cancer psychologists determining
whether somebody has a treatable problem
or not college administrators try to
determine who to let in all of them are
outperformed I don't know give her the
book algorithms to live by yes okay so
that my favorite example of this is they
go that is really military and in the
officer training course and they
basically you know it's early in the
training course and they say to somebody
you know pick who's gonna be the best
officer and they give some criteria as
to what that definition is and they
almost always pick the strongest looking
most you know egotistical kind of type-a
personality is that's that's the one
that's gonna lead us into battle they're
gonna be the best and when the bullets
start flying usually they're the one who
you know runs into the truck and gets on
the radio you know it's really funny I
read a guy who's really into geopolitics
and and one of his quips was actually
yeah it was an interesting piece but he
was saying he would show a picture of
soldiers right and he goes who are the
best soldiers here and of course you go
to the strap guys with the big arms and
everything the guy who looks like you
they are the skinniest wiry as' because
they're fast yep they're smart and they
know that they have the muscle memory
for just everything they got to do yep
so appearances really can be conceiving
or deceiving and you know I think that's
kind of the that's the thing that's
interesting with crypto I think that I
think that once there is kind of an
agreed-upon set of rules mm-hmm that
then crypto could do pretty well I think
that and again I don't know because I am
no crypto expert but I think that you
know institutional participation is
vital yep you've definitely got to get
the bigger financial institutions being
willing yep and once that happens then
then things might they might develop in
a way unexpected or unfor casted but if
they're involved my guess is that that
is an Imperator that you don't like have
right now right a lot of it is being
announced
and they're planning on doing but you
know it's kind of like we'll wait until
the cash is in the bank and when you
have that moment I think I think that
will be a real milestone for the
cryptocurrency community because that
lending the legitimacy of some of these
big financial institutions you know that
that could be huge
absolutely what um what's the best piece
of a financial investment advice you've
ever received right in terms of from
another investor what's the best piece
of advice I ever gave you well I have a
friend named Brent B Shore and this is
gonna be advice through Brent because it
didn't come directly from Brent Brent is
fantastic it came from Warren Buffett
and Brent went to a dinner with him and
by the way full disclosure our family is
involved with an investment in Brent
anyway
Brent is a very detail-oriented guy and
a really super nice guy
and you know he wanted to hear all about
Buffett's diligence and you know he had
his paper ready to take his notes and
Buffett looked at him and he goes prices
my only diligence and as I kind of
thought about that I thought wow that is
like really brilliant right because at
some point everything gets worth buying
if it's functioning and you know it's
not a legal there's not some quagmire
that you're stepping into yep and and
it's kind of like yeah I mean ultimately
Jamie Diana Diamond once said give me a
C rank plan with a ranked players and
I'll take that all day long over an
a-rank plan with C rate players
mm-hmm so I think you know most
investment advice is really elemental
mm-hmm and and it speaks to what I call
the wall well duh right you know so you
hear Buffett say
Isis my only diligence and you think
well if it wasn't Warren Buffett no one
would pay any attention to him but they
would they would because when you think
about it and you wrap that around your
head and and I looked at Brea or Brenton
went wow that's that's really profound
mm-hmm so I think one one of the things
that I've been on recently is look I
believe that people if they want to be
great investors they have to create
their investment scheme that's right for
them mm-hmm what is right for me might
not be right for you
read as much as you can and read outside
the field of Finance definitely but as
you do that take notes see what
resonates with you see what doesn't ask
yourself would I really be able to
withstand that kind of downturn and then
ask yourself and I owe an even more
obvious question okay how did I perform
during the financial crisis if I sold
all my stocks in January or February I
know I got a problem and then I got to
try to build an investment strategy that
will work for me listen good investing
is simple it's just not easy mm-hmm and
and that is you know something that a
lot of people you know go back to basic
principles and you know get somebody to
be a wingman for you because for the
most part you'll panic I used to say to
people you know do a letter from your
advisor that's from you that says dear
mr. advisor mrs. advisor I know that at
some point in the future I will panic
about you know and then leave a space
where you can fill it in and you are
gonna tell me what a stupid idea that is
for me and then show it to me at the
time again as long as human nature
remains what it is I got a day job
absolutely what um what element of
crypto do you think is most analogous to
the work that you guys do
right so you guys are very
quantitatively driven you're very aware
of human psychology and kind of the
market forces that are driven by that we
look at the crypto market you know and
you look at your business what's the
thing where you're like you know that
makes a lot of sense to apply this
approach - sure so the only thing that
we would have in our toolkit that I
would just sort of say was a natural for
crypto would be our momentum composite
you know most CPAs are momentum players
and when you look at the most successful
models in you know cotton and gold and
whatever their momentum models I mean
because you know there aren't really
fundamentals in crypto and so I would
think that momentum could be very
applicable mm-hmm
and we have many different types of
momentum the one we use the most is a
composite of momentum that includes
standard deviation of return so it it
penalizes the most volatile and it gives
more support to the less volatile I
could see that working pretty nicely I
mean it you know if somebody said Jim
you know I'm putting a gun to your head
and you got to trade this crypto and you
better make some money
I would definitely use the momentum it's
it's amazing all right so I end each
podcast by letting the guest ask me one
question and before I let you do that
I'll give you a second to think I have
to comment because I have been impressed
with your gif game on Twitter for those
of you that don't know Jim is is quite
active on Twitter and over the last
couple of weeks all of a sudden it's
like he discovered the the gif feature
and has been lighting the internet on
fire and and I have literally laughed
out loud a few times when I speak about
things that you've posted well thank you
look I I think that you know here's
another thing that I've found is that
most of the smartest people I've ever
met and I've met a lot of people in my
life I've been very very blessed and
lucky most of the smartest people I've
met in life have a good sense of
and and and that's for two reasons right
because a good sense of humor also sees
the dark side right and so I figure
gifts if we can't laugh have a little
fun you know what what's a day for all
right the question that I have for you
is why did you abandon your logo that I
retag on to your messages Oh iris is
ready I love that the virus is spreading
with with the rocket
alright so because you're asking I will
I will let one of my secrets go so I
think of Twitter as a combination
between conversations that we're all
having on the internet as characters of
ourselves right yeah and so if you were
to look at Twitter through the lens of
WWE for example right right and I asked
you I said you know who is the hero who
is the you know villain who is the kind
of that the clowny person right and and
who is the announcer and you could
probably say that first it kind of fits
that that character right and so the
first time that I said it was not
intentional in kind of any grand plan
but the logic often how things go of
course but the logic behind it was
everyone's worried about the technology
right but what what was fascinating me
and I think you know why I'm drawn to a
lot of things that you're thinking about
is the psychological element of this it
was capturing the mental energy of
everyone right across every industry
across every age demographic Geographic
locate I mean just every it's a good
meme right very good me and when it was
I was like this is this is viral right
and in the sense of kind of from the
technology world but it's spreading like
a virus cuz no one can stop it right
when a product goes viral you can
basically pull the plug and stop the
growth with that virus a lot of times
you can't stop it and so I was like you
know the virus is spreading
and internet lit up right and people
kept saying it over and over and over
again you were off for a little while
and you came back and I saw that you
didn't have it and I actually put it up
well the reason so so when I came back
there was two things that as to why and
it wasn't again not even really
intentional but when I took when I took
the Twitter break what I realized was it
just Twitter specifically and I was
during a drawdown it was you know do all
draw a story I think that a little more
sobriety well the pro in the con of all
of this playing out digitally right and
kind of on Twitter is is this idea that
somebody can come up with a thought a
thesis you know whatever throw it out
into the open yeah and there's people
from all walks of life all perspectives
all levels of success and failure and
they just attack right true now true the
good part of that is the law of
attrition takes over and so the ideas
that can withstand those attacks are
usually the strongest and have the most
merit and kind of end up persisting over
some long period of time but there's a
lot of ideas that never make it to the
future you know there's a guy on Twitter
who I follow and actually support his
work he's called mimetic value okay and
he has a really interesting deck about
you know John Campbell's the hero's
journey
yep and how you know every story that we
hear is like one of six but one of his
ideas is there always has to be a
scapegoat and he talks about how the
scapegoat Steve Jobs turned into the
hero and it's really interesting I'll
send you the link because I think you'd
enjoy following and for sure what
Twitter is a is one of the places where
again I think human psychology
incentives just play out perfectly you
know it is the world's largest
psychology experiment ever conducted and
we still know how it's gonna turn out 50
years from now when they are when they
are going through the data and they see
your
gifts okay you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna throw sand in the wheels
there this is awesome thank you so much
for for coming in and share your
perspective of the race thanks for
having me